dan dockage former college coach former
college player ESPN college basketball
analyst also works for 1070 the fan in
indianapolis dan thanks for joining us
let me start with Louisville was an
appropriate punishment in your opinion
for Louisville you know I go back and
forth with it you know III don't know
what really vacating wins does I don't
know what really vacating titles does I
but I do so that's one side the other
side is you know what if you if you are
gonna have rules you only have so many
ways you can punish and everybody says
well you got to punish in a checkbook
and I get that I do and so they're gonna
they're gonna give back funds but I
think you've got to do something else
but it I don't know it just seems like
what we say the games didn't count what
we say the games you know take it back
their rings Michigan the champ what's
the move I just don't I don't know I've
never been overly like yeah I've always
been more let's get rid of the coach
let's get rid of the system let's get
rid of the the guys involved but I do
understand you gotta have certain
deterrence I mean you have to have
deterrence you can't just have rules and
you know a little slaps on the wrist and
this is not a slap on the wrist Big D
this is forever or at least for the time
being as long as I've been alive it's
the only team that's ever had a banner
championship taking down Benson Final
Fours but it's a huge deterrent I would
hope but I like the fact more than
anything they got rid of 14 a guy rich
and they can move forward I think how
involved do you think Pitino was how
aware do you think he was of what was
going on you know I can't imagine that
he wasn't III just can't imagine now if
you're gonna tell me one night they had
hookers in the dorm because the seventh
assistant decided that that was what he
was going to do and players wanted to do
it and I'd say I maybe didn't know if
you're gonna tell me one night but then
you're talking about and you're talking
about years and you're talking about a
guy that built the place you're talking
about a guy who hired the assistant and
even if he didn't know didn't he set the
culture that that's okay yeah like I
always like the fact that a guy was
writing a book on the culture of
athletics and he interviewed my team at
Bowling Green and he came back he said
your team has scared to death to screw
up I said that's right I said they
should be they're scared of death to do
anything illegal take anything from a
booster they're scared of death to do
anything with the law and I said that's
how it should be it's a privilege to
play college basketball so whether he
knew or not the culture was over years
they had you know how silly this
prostitutes in their dorm I mean Dan
just think about that just for a second
like just think about we're gonna build
a basketball dorm we're gonna have one
of our assistants bring hookers into the
dorm to meet recruits I mean just think
about that right there means you head
coach has got to get fired right there
means the school's got a serious problem
and where's the media you know what you
know the Louisville media everybody says
well you know nobody spoke well we've
seen the power of investigative
reporters over the last few years we've
seen the power of media finding uh
following up on tips you know over the
last few months certainly where was a
Louisville media in all this where they
just fanboys or where were they cuz
somebody's talking somewhere and you
know they're just allowed it to happen
this Pitino get another job MBA probably
for sure college maybe after a few years
Dan you know this you know as well as
anybody that man winning is strong and
Pitino goes in there and talk to some
made the hell Calvin Sampson got a job
yeah after twice and you know I mean so
yeah you looked the great Royce Waldman
who many people have never heard that
was a great coach philosopher said very
clearly get fired for anything but
losing you get fired for lose you never
gonna get another job depart for
anything how's this gonna play this FBI
investigation that's supposed to have
this big net that's gonna be draped over
college basketball what are you hearing
about the fallout from this well you
know I it's interesting I'm not sure
what I'm hearing
nobody heard anything for three years
people even know what's going on and I'm
being literal not figurative literally
didn't know what was going on but
obviously now people have talked and
obviously people who's a really good
investigative reporter you know came out
and said very publicly and very sternly
that this is going to be an issue and
Hall of Fame coaches Dan I don't know
the one thing that I I like about it is
that guys that didn't she have nothing
to worry about and literally are
celebrating and hoping that things come
out because the guys at do cheat
everybody wants wants them exposed and
you know the n-c-double-a didn't have
enough of a hammer I don't know the one
thing I don't like though is people's
perception that everybody cheats I
didn't cheat coach I didn't cheat Don
Danaher didn't she I mean you know so I
don't know and to say that if anybody
says they do no I think it's
disingenuous but I do think this and I
do Lee there are a lot of dudes with a
lot of wind having a lot of sleepless
nights okay but how do I see now Dan how
do I cheat yeah dan I don't know because
you know I've never ran in those circles
and and everybody says well we we know
the cheaters and I always say really who
and how what I hear is the biggest
problem
coaches have is Andy Miller who is a
big-time agent they went into his office
and they took his computers they got his
financial records and that's has the
most people worried and that's what
everybody tells me Andy Miller agents
records financial statements you know
that's what those guys check persons
arrest them got arrested for then get
arrested percent son come here and we'll
you know will pave your mother's
driveway or well you know buy a new car
or they arrest for that they get
arrested for all kind of financial stuff
so that's the place where where people
are supposedly the most nervous agents
financial records best player in college
basketball is number 13 point guard at
Ohio State University and roodaka or
Jalen Brunson the point guard
at Villanova or or you know I really I
know we're supposed to you know be tired
I guess of Trey young but I liked rayon
I didn't trade I've had a magical year
Dan but I really think that Jalen
Brunson has put himself and his team in
a great position man and and he's got to
be considered ok but who is who is your
pick is the best player in college
basketball
ok long answer yeah sometimes you ask me
what time it is I tell you how to watch
I go Jalen Brunson but man you know we
built up Trey young so big and now he's
had a few big games everybody wants to
jump off the fan wagon I guess including
me but I just think Jalen Brunson is a
winning guy and he does it every night
safe travels we'll talk to you as we
head towards March Madness thank you
buddy that's a dandaka GSB in college
basketball analyst dental Tire Coach's
Corner brings us dandaka ch Continental
Tire proud supporter the Dan Patrick
show the exclusive tire the Dan Patrick
show no matter where you drive or what
you drive Continental designs tires for
what you do for more information visit
Continental Tire com Continental Tire
for what you do for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
at
[Music]